hi I'm Eric vos and this is a breakdown
of The Walking Dead Season eight episode
3 monsters that's right just when we
started to get used to having loose and
Morales back on the show
Daryl decided this world ain't big
enough for another season one survivor
I'm gonna talk about shoot first Daryl
in this episode later along with some
subtle connections and deeper insights
that you might not normally consider I
also might have come across a pretty
huge bombshell which for a show that is
usually pretty obvious about where it
said it and sticks almost religiously to
the comics that's saying something so
hold onto your butts let's get started
with this week's big question tweeted to
us by Mikey is Daryl too far gone good
question Mike and it's worth discussing
after ruthlessly putting down Morales
even when he knew it was him as well as
the young savior who helped them out
later
both times against Rick's wishes what
does this say about Darrow's moral
character like it's Daryl evil and Kyle
Volkmann I know you disagreed I just
want to give you a shout-out thanks for
watching these videos man so here's the
deal with Daryl yes I do believe he is
too far gone but I also think he's been
too far gone for several seasons now
remember this is the same guy who fired
the first shot and the war against the
Savior's by blowing up a handful of them
with an RPG in season six
he murdered fat Joey when he escaped the
sanctuary even with fat joey begging for
his life and then he joined rick and
slaughtering gareth and the other
terminus cannibals back in season five
and he was really a trigger finger away
from blowing away Jesus and Dwight at
different points Daryl has always been a
cold killer who doesn't want to hear a
debate it's actually hard to imagine
what Daryl would do Bend before it's
society collapse because he seems so
driven now so much a product of this
chaotic world it's actually interesting
that Daryl was purely a creation for the
show he's one of the few characters not
in the comics it's almost like when AMC
adapted this comic into a human drama
Norman Reedus is Daryl was a natural
result of bringing this world to life so
yes Daryl is too far gone but he's also
too far gone for a reason to compare to
Rick Rick is a lawman the moral center
of this show the leader who straddles
the line between
and trust Darryl is there to show Rick
and us what sheriff crimes would look
like if he totally gave in to caution
that all ties into the deeper meaning
this episode which I'll get to later but
I should also say that being too far
gone doesn't make darrell heartless or
evil either he's obviously not negan the
guy just has a soft spot for Carol let's
not forget but I think his affection for
her stems from their shared too far-gone
worldview both of them have their
shattered their souls doing the
unthinkable that in their eyes had to be
done so really any love between Carol
and Daryl is just a common affection
between two very broken hearts you know
kind of like two chewed on Lego pieces
that somehow fit together
anyway Daryl's sudden killing of Morales
might also be seen as a callback to
Moore Alice's two parts Rebecca in
season one remember when Rick and Shane
gave Morales a gun and half a box of
ammo Daryl was pissed so perhaps this
grudge came bubbling back up to the
surface when he saw Morales pointing a
gun at Rick like seven we let this
with supplies we needed after he
abandoned us and now this is how he
returns the favor f that let's actually
point out all the other ways this
episode connected to past episodes and
our segments callbacks
okay so early in the episode Ezekiel and
Carol's group is surrounded by a bunch
of saviors who whistle creepily at them
obviously this is a callback to the
Savior's surrounding Rick and his people
back in the season 6 finale when negan
first appeared on the show
and speaking of whistling the obnoxious
Savior Jared whistles that random ballet
song as Jesus and Morgan March the
prisoners back to the hilltop you know
that except this isn't random
it's Tchaikovsky's dance of the
mirlitons from The Nutcracker like some
of you guys I'm sure I was dragging my
sisters annual Nutcracker recital so
this music is seared on in my brain this
is actually part of a long tradition of
the Savior's reference say in classical
music
last season Eugene played another
Tchaikovsky classic the 1812 overture
when he set off those homemade fireworks
of a sanctuary can also be that Jaden
Eugene just listen to the same
Tchaikovsky's greatest hits album also
earlier last season Simon blared another
classical music song during the walker
attack of the hilltop that was Jean
Sibelius is Finlandia opus number 26 so
my guy says the Savior's are doing this
to strike fear into the hearts of their
enemies though in this case Jared's
Nutcracker tune is more playful and
light-hearted sounds like maybe he's
trying to get under Morgan's skin and
taunt him
now during the scene Jesus and Morgan
debate with Jesus saying we kill but we
do not execute and Morgan responds I
have this is a callback to Morgan's past
execution of a man he really didn't need
to kill Richard at the kingdom it was
Richard screwing around with the melon
count have led to been getting shot
leaving Morgan to kill Richard out of
anger
Jared also calls out Morgan's small
armor which belonged to Ben which I
pointed on past breakdowns again I think
it's interesting that this also serves
as metaphorical armor hardening Morgan
against the world and having to process
his grief now at the end of this episode
Morgan after getting his ass handed to
him by Jesus flips a and says I
can't be part of this which is an echo
of Carole's sentiments at the end of
season six that's interesting how
Carole's warnings eventually caught up
to Morgan with their own brutality
frightening them into isolation now
there's definitely a parallel in the way
Eric was left bleeding out against a
tree and in season one the way we left
that guy Jim along with Morales in the
handcuffs shot last episode and the
shots of Karl in the premiere I think
this is one of the many nods back to
season one now one other call that I
want to point out is the hands down
honey slow Matt this episode the first
time I've really laughed at The Walking
Dead at all this season
Gregory begging to be let back into the
hilltop and bickering with Cal over
whether or not he ate a little girl's
sorghum pancakes
you know Gregory totally ate those
pancakes as we saw last season this
piece of secretly hoards food
supplies all the time he hid a box of
scotch in his closet what's to stop him
from stealing sorghum from a baby moving
on I was gonna do a hole under the
influence section to talk about the
cultural references this episode but
really I only kind of felt Rick and
Daryl shooting down different ends of
the hallway before using spilling gas
from a fire extinguisher to mask their
escape it's kind of something you would
see out of that arcade game time crisis
to know I just really enjoyed this
action and Daryl's suddenly shooting
this savior kid before Rick could stop
him reminded me a lot of my favorite
episode of the show Breaking Bad when
Todd coldly shoots a kid who witnesses
their crime without really consulting
anyone else but really I want to talk
about some visual details I spotted
while looking at this imagery closely so
let's take a closer look in our segment
zoom in enhance
okay now some people were asking about
what exactly happened to Eric this
episode like Aaron left him at the tree
came back later to find a
blood stain and in the distance
smattering of walkers staggering away
now Aaron never actually goes after them
to check and Scott keeps telling him
that it isn't Erik trying to hold him
back but yeah if you look closely at
that Walker it's wearing the same shirt
and jacket tied around his waist that
Eric did when Aaron left him so our IP
Eric while your death was a bit more
ambiguous at least the TV adaptation
received a more thoughtful and heartfelt
farewell than Eric did in issue number
118 of the comics and there's an even
bigger missable detail I want to talk
about but first I want to quickly thank
the sponsor of this video Vikings war of
clans if you've never played before
now's the perfect time to start the new
game version is great it resembles a top
PC strategy game to the 90s and 2000's
and now it's on mobile so you can easily
plan a five-minute break of work
Vikings gives you an option to choose
your own play style dominate by
destroying cities building impregnable
fortress azure even using diplomacy now
I prefer destroying cities really just
play for five minutes and you'll see why
me and two million folks worldwide are
addicted to it come find me in the game
I'm new rockstars underscore Eric we can
play together so support our channel
download Vikings from the links below
and get our special bonus of two hundred
gold for a fast and successful start ok
back to the episode let's talk about
this baby Rick found and they save your
outpost Gracie Rick mercifully brings
this baby with them handing her off to
Aaron to take to the hilltop but there's
a crazy detail they didn't point out my
last breakdown in the baby's crib was
this stuffed rabbit
we actually saw this stuffed rabbit
somewhere else this season in the hands
of this little girl in Rick's old man
vision at the season premiere and we all
assumed this was Judith or some
alternate reality version of Judith but
now I don't think so I think this is
Gracie
so let's activate theory time to dig
deeper into what's going on here ok
first off this isn't just a production
coincidence walking to a prop master
John Sanders confirmed he did have to
acquire two Velveteen rabbits for the
show one that looks fresh and new and
another that looks old and worn
he actually said ordering these rabbits
from Scotland was a big ordeal and he
could only get them by explaining to the
manufacturer how big a deal they would
be on the show so yeah I think we're
onto something here so there's a couple
scenarios we can look at one is that
this little girl in the vision is Judith
but Rick took Gracie's rabbit and gave
it to her
which I guess would be more of a Gregory
move or maybe the girls just became
friends and they you know trade toys but
I think the more likely and way darker
scenario is the theory proposed back in
my episode one breakdown
I think distraught looking Rick was
burying Judith a character who no longer
exists at this point in the comics and a
loved one whose death would definitely
be enough to make Rick this upset
come on those eyes are just screaming
rule and how after most mercifully
rescuing baby Gracie Rick could bring
her in as a new daughter in fact this
act of mercy here could be connected to
that episode being titled mercy let me
know what you think but for now let's
move on to the deeper meaning of this
episode episode threes titled monsters
bringing up the question who are the
monsters of the episode the our forces
us to look at the characters like Rick
Morgan and Daryl and new monstrous
lights as arguably the more villainous
side of this war against a saviors early
in the episode Morales uses the word
monster to describe Rick a man who just
like him is an who will do
whatever it takes to keep going and I
think this parallelism explains more
Alice's brief return to the show just
for this one conversation he's a ghost
from the past who reflects Rick's
monstrosity back to him an image of what
Rick could have become under slightly
different circumstances but just as Rick
begs Morales to find another way those
same words are spoken by Jesus to Morgan
who like Morales considers himself
beyond redemption in his eyes he and
everyone else is just another monster
waiting to turn but in a spiritual sense
Morgan's Rumble with Jesus almost feels
like a symbolic struggle against
salvation Jesus overpowering him is a
key reflection of the hope that the show
wants to leave us with as Jesus said we
kill but we do not execute meaning we
may have to act monstrously at times but
that doesn't make us monsters and for
any pastors watching feel free to lift
that for your sermons on Sunday but it
sorry to cut this good Christian moral
with a celebration of violence but
that's kind of what the market that is
so let's check in on this week's kill
count
topping the list says this week's
deadliest survivor is Daryl with one
Walker but for on-screen human kills
including the ruthless kills of Morales
and that younger Savior later on
given Darryl's role on the show guys
just expect those bodies to keep piling
up and let's move on to a few
predictions for next week's episode
episode 4 titled
some guy this episode ended with the
cliffhanger of Ezekiel's group under
heavy fire at Gavin's compound promo
footage from episode 4 shows Carol
isolated inside that compound and the
prized weapon that Rick was after that
is the 50 caliber browning machine gun
that we saw described in Rick's note
last episode as we saw in the final
shots whoever's in control of this thing
is a huge advantage in this all-out war
after Eric this episode I also feel like
episode 4 could deliver some more
heartbreaking casualties there was that
one shot of Jerry in the trailer when he
looked bloodied up and he thanked
Ezekiel for being such a cool dude it
seems like that could be from episode 4
and I don't know it seems a lot more
morbid now hopefully Jerry won't be the
some guy of the episodes title who you
know lays down his life or something do
you think Daryl's deadliness makes him
less likable or does it make him more
likable I'm curious to hear your
thoughts on this now I want to thank you
guys for watching these breakdowns
whether you just started this season or
whether you've been watching since
season 6 those of you who've been
tweeting me and leaving these supportive
comments guys it means so much now I
know the format has changed to be a
little less flashy without all the bells
and whistles that we had before and I
totally get the adjustment you guys are
having to make but I also like to think
this lets maybe more streamline and just
get to the stuff that you really care
about like the connections and the
deeper insights clip honestly less of me
having a through some points
now I don't want to get too much into it
but we also kind of have to do the
walking dead breakdowns this way the
biggest reason is that this YouTube ad
pocalypse stuff that I honestly really
don't understand am see more than other
networks is super overprotective of
their properties and these days YouTube
will just preemptively take down our
videos or D monetize them even when they
easily fall under fair use it's just a
huge headache that honestly kept us from
breaking down half a season 6 if you
guys remember so to do breakdowns the
old way with lots of footage from the
episodes which just put a big stupid
unfair target on our backs
also we cover a lot of stuff on this
channel and our editors are currently
swamped so me doing Walking Dead
breakdowns like this is really the only
way you're gonna get any walk-ins have
breakdowns I'm sorry but again most
you guys seem to be really enjoying them
so for the rest of you maybe just
pretend like you just stumbled upon
these breakdowns this season like you
would probably just be happy they
existed at all right but again thank you
guys so much for all your support we
would honestly love to be able to do
these videos free from the unfair
YouTube restrictions or sure having to
interrupt them with ads but really the
best way to help us do that is to
contribute to us on patreon you can be
part of our team and help us decide what
content to make and really make our
channel truly independent simply for you
guys big thanks to all of our current
team members especially Christina
Armstrong hit me up in the comments down
below or tweet me at EI vos or probably
new rockstars on twitter at new
rockstars for updates on our videos and
like and share this video and subscribe
to new rock stars on this channel for
more analysis of The Walking Dead and
other stuff that you love thanks for
watching guys bye